rich Larry in your book legacy paying
the price for the Clinton years buried
in your book page 301 Clinton was a
weepy undisciplined talkative indecisive
sexually incontinent embodiment of
America's alleged weakness and
corruption how long did it take you to
think that one else
well that was towards the end of the
book so I'd spent you know a year
thinking about this guy reading about
him talking to people about him and you
know that was his weakness he had had
many strengths he was very articulate
he's very smart he excellent obviously
of forging connections with people in a
very short time but his problem was that
he lacked strength and as I say in the
book they're really two basic
ingredients to presidential leadership
you need basic fundamental governing
principles and character and Clinton
unfortunately had neither of those what
would you say to someone who is a big
fan of Bill Clinton's who's reaching for
the clicker at this point saying I don't
have to put up with this anymore I'm not
gonna listen to rich Lowry I would say
listen to this and let's have a factual
discussion about what really happened in
the 1990s and that's what this book is
all about it's not a hate book there are
plenty of criticisms of Clinton very
sharp ones that you've just read one in
this book but I took a lot of time and a
lot of care to be as factual and
fair-minded as possible to really engage
in these arguments in a serious way you
also compared in the book Richard Nixon
with Bill Clinton and George Bush and
Bill Clinton ears what you said about
the bush clinton connection clinton is
is chronically late Bush a stickler for
promptness Clinton tolerated casual wear
or even less than the Oval Office Bush
insists on coat and tie Clinton is
verbose and slippery Bush terse and
blunt the most important difference is
that Bush represents a different aspect
of America a part of the country that is
less touchy-feely is more insistent on
personal accountability and importantly
is more at home with the military it is
the other America
yeah this is a split that was always
been out there in the country but was
really highlighted in the Clinton years
and his initial genius Clinton was being
able to sort of paper over this this gap
you know he went to Yale Law School he
hobnob with celebrities yet he had this
Bubba side of him you know he's from
Arkansas he talked about having
astroturf in the back of his truck when
he was a young man but what happened
especially in the Monica scandal as the
country has really polarized culturally
and part of the reason we're having such
a vicious fight over the Clinton and
Bush records and presidencies is because
they both represent the opposite
extremes in that cultural split and
we're getting a very stark sort of
experiment in two different styles of
guy in the oval oval office and two
different styles of governance go back
to your statement about George Bush
represents a different aspect of America
is more insistent on personal
accountability what evidence you have of
that
well Clinton the whole idea was that he
could say one thing and do another he
could you know have sex with an intern
in the Oval Office and lie about it and
this was all supposed to be forgotten
and kind of a haze of emotion and
feeling I'm very sorry I get a little
misty eyed and we go and talk about it
on Oprah and forget about it and Bush
just represents a sterner aspect of
America and it's it's caught most I
think most starkly and most in the most
relevant way for these guys as commander
in chief and the sort of relationship
they have with the military Clinton got
off on the wrong foot with these guys
the military won because of his draft
history too because he was pushing gays
in the military three just because of
the kind of guy he is
Bill Clinton you know the sort of folks
who inhabit the combat arms in the
military just don't have a natural
connection with him they do with George
Bush now whatever you say about his
landing on the the aircraft carrier
whether that was a political stunt
whether it was premature
you could see the very real connection
between those guys and George Bush and
that's because Bush is a red state
American when he goes on vacation he
doesn't go to Martha's Vineyard to hang
out with intellectuals and celebrities
he goes to clear brush on his ranch and
that's the kind of thing folks in the
military connect with more naturally
than Bill Clinton go back to the
statement that he doesn't say one thing
and do another if you had somebody
across from me right now that was on the
other side they would say well he told
us all during the campaign
no nation-building and now we're
spending right billions and billions on
nation-building right what about well
that's that's a good point now that what
has happened is circumstances have
changed and I think the right as a
general matter with too dismissive of
nation-building because of the
experience we had in the 1990s when it
was almost always undertaken in
countries or areas that were peripheral
to America's national interest you know
we did a huge amount of nation-building
in Europe after World War two we did
nation-building in various forms during
the Cold War
these were exercises that were very much
in America's national interest and what
Bush and other conservatives realized
after 9/11 is that sometimes is very
much in the country's interest to reach
into other nations and affect how they
are governed so circumstance has changed
but you know Bush was always I think you
always knew what his reaction would be
to some sort of attack of that nature he
was asked in the very first Republican
presidential debate when he was at his
most sort of stumbly and and worst and
least comfortable what would you do if
someone told you Saddam had acquired
weapons of mass destruction or a nuclear
bomb I forget exactly what the the
question was and Bush said I take him
out and it was a question afterwards
whether he said I would take him out or
take them out it turned out he he
probably meant both on the back of your
book you're endorsed by William F
Buckley your boss peggy noonan michael
barone and rush limbaugh you are the
editor of the National
what does that mean and how long have
you had that job as an editor of
National Review since the beginning of
1998 national view is generally taken as
the Bible of American conservatism as
where people conservatives go to get
their marching orders orders it's where
internal and intramural conservative
disputes are kind of hashed out and has
had that role for you know going on 50
years just for a minute what's the
difference between the National Journal
the Weekly Standard and the American
Spectator well let's see the Weekly
Standard is in inside Washington it
comes out once a week so it's more more
sort of insider 'i feel if you want to
know the minutiae of what is the
obsession in washington of the hour you
go to the Weekly Standard it also has a
very neo Khan bent which is a phrase
it's been a word that's been misused a
lot recently but basically means they're
much more enthusiastic about spreading
democracy abroad as a general matter
they're a little less concerned with
limiting government and cutting taxes
than other conservatives are due to what
Bill Kristol is the editor of that
publication and you the editor of
National Review differ on very many
things it would all be nuances it would
mean a lot probably to each of us
individually but the average person out
in the country probably couldn't find
you know much of a difference
intervention in a place like Sierra
Leone or you know someplace in Africa
that's not so important we might have
slightly different takes on that we
might have different takes about how
easy it is to spread democracy in
various places abroad but the
differences are very small and one one
sort of misconception in the whole
Iraq debate is that every certain people
have argued that anyone in favor of
going into Iraq was a neoconservative
which was absolutely insane you had a
real conservative consensus of all
stripes except for a very small number
of paleo conservatives who were in favor
of this whether their neoconservatives
who wanted to do it to spread democracy
or whether their more national security
realist type conservatives who just
wanted to do it because Saddam
represented a threat to us so how does
it differ with Bob materials the
American Spectator which got a lot of
visibility during the Clinton years for
wanting to get him out of the office I
don't know it's hard to the American
Spectator in its current version it's a
little hard to tell what a specific
ideological imprint it's back after
being owned or run by George Gilder for
a while butts back in Bob Toros hands
yeah I think it's it's a sort of
standard conservative publication and
what's always set them apart
besides the the scandal coverage they
did in the 1990s was having a sense of
humor being real Outsiders kind of
throwing bombs and making fun of people
and it's so I think it's more a
sensibility with the American Spectator
rather than an ideological slant
I ask you all these questions cause if
you now know where you're coming from I
want to ask you this was the point that
I got throughout this whole book and I
want to read every single name why did
these people talk to you these are all
former Clinton administration people who
you have quoted in here
fresh Eric Holder was at the Justice
Department Bernie Nussbaum the counsel
at the White House Richard Holbrooke the
UN Ambassador Wayne downing was he in
the Clinton White House was not in the
Clinton White House he was the head of
US Special Forces up till around in 1995
or 1990s but left the Bush White House
not happy with the situation that's
right
Howard pasture the congressional liaison
Bruce Reid Robert rice the former labor
secretary Paul glass trous that's what
you pronounce it that makes me editor of
the Washington Monthly now that's right
and at the time was a meat rider
speechwriter Leon Panetta Don Bear Leon
Panetta was the budget manager and also
the chief of staff Don bear
communications Alice Rivlin was that OMB
OMB for a while but she also went over
to the reserve Ellen Carmack Elaine
Carmack her job a mark he does it she
was a domestic adviser she headed the
reinventing government and then became
she was associated with Al Gore Bill
Daley who ran the gore campaign but also
was at calmer
and Tony like the National Security
Adviser why did these people talk to you
the editor of National Review about Bill
Clinton they're also I have to say many
others that I just couldn't quote by
name well there's a there's a lot of
former officials quoted unnamed right I
think they just want to get it's
differing reasons some of them are just
temperamental II inclined to talk to any
reporter others of them I think are just
very are intellectually honest people
and just want to engage in the
give-and-take and try to convince you
others are just very friendly and open I
would hope my reputation for the kind of
writing I've done in the past helped
convince some of them to talk to me
knowing knowing where I was coming from
and there's a lot of joking about that
with some of these guys but also knowing
that you know I wasn't gonna mangle
their quotes or distort them and I would
legitimately try to understand where
they're coming from and you know modify
my thinking accordingly did you happen
to go did you go back to each one and
check the quotes with him or it differed
some of them were just you know plopped
down your tape recorder and use whatever
you want others the most most of them I
had conversations on background with
them with the understanding that would
come back with on the record quotes so
they could approve them and that that
reflected a certain level of discomfort
you know they wanted to be absolutely
sure I wasn't taking things out of
context or distorting them and sign off
before I actually use them did you try
to talk to Bill Clinton or Hillary
Clinton I did not try to talk to Hillary
I considered it basically fruitless I
did put in an interview request with
Bill Clinton and never heard back from
this office and are there others that
you wanted to talk to that wouldn't talk
to you yeah it differed there are some
who just you know wouldn't answer my
calls there are others who just said no
I'm not interested in talking to you but
I tried to get to as many as I could
because obviously the more of these
people you talk to the deeper your
understanding of what they were up to
these quotes I'm going to read are out
of context but I just wanted to okay
well I have a beef with you that not me
yeah but what I'm the reason I want to
do this is you can put them in context
and why they said with the Richard
Holbrooke former UN Ambassador Clinton
is profoundly intuitive his mind works
like nothing I've ever seen he's
brilliant and is able to see every side
of each issue this is usually an
advantage but not always that's a very
nice way of saying this guy is extremely
smart but he couldn't make a decision
and his intelligence in some way some
ways worked against him because he it
made him indecisive and that's a key
quality you want in a present is to be
able to make a decision and just stick
with it and not agonize over it and not
change your mind 24 hours later and
Clinton did that again and again and
Bosnia for instance if you look at the
three year history of the administration
trying to deal with that crisis right at
the beginning he sends Warren
Christopher to go argue the Europeans
into accepting a strategy of so-called
lift and strike lifting the arms embargo
on the Bosnian Muslims and hitting the
Serbs with air strikes if necessary well
Christopher is there in Europe
physically going from capital to capital
bill clinton reads an op-ed in The Wall
Street Journal which in his way is very
admirable right this guy is engaged in
the debate he's interested in what
people are writing and he reads it he
changes his mind and before Warren
Christopher has come back Bill Clinton
has a band in this policy because he's
read one op-ed and that's the weakness
that dick Holbrooke is talking about Don
Baer who was in the Communications
Office I think he never wanted to make
snap judgments he has a very very active
and engaged intelligence I think he
wanted to understand the various sides
of issues before he came down hard on
them even though he started from a
certain set of principles that he
believed were right it may be that
process of doing that at the end of the
day required too much time and too much
lack of discipline to really focus
himself and his administration that's
really exactly the same point as as
Holbrooke was making Howard pasture
senior staff meetings grew to 35 to 45
people anybody could come there wasn't
any list circulated they had chairs
three deep in the Roosevelt Room you
don't run a place like that yeah he's
talking about the early chaos in the
administration which actually exactly
mirrored the chaos in the initial two
years of Clinton's
govenor ship in Arkansas and it
reflected again his character where to
have some discipline and run a place
with some order you have to be able to
tell people no you know no you cannot
come to this meeting they're just gonna
be five of us these are the important
people these are the people I need to
hear from and Clinton was just unable to
do that and he was you know constantly
running late and disorganized himself he
didn't really trust a chief of staff he
didn't want to have a strong chief of
staff because he would have felt
threatened by such a person so therefore
it was chaos and these were a bunch of
kids who you know thought they're just
finally gonna show the old fogies how
you really run such a place and they
made it a huge mess of it a former
senior administration official when you
call somebody a senior administration
official how senior is that that's a
good question because almost everyone
wants to be wants to be identified as a
senior administration official the way I
would put it it's it's someone whose
name you would recognize could it be
someone that you've talked to already
and they say at this point don't quote
me personally on this but use my quote
yes it could be either someone I've
quoted by name elsewhere or it could be
someone just entirely different alright
here's what the former senior
administration official said most of the
leaks were coming because people were
trying to show to a journalist friends
of theirs that they were in the room and
had a hand in big decisions many people
who witnessed it would call it the
Stephanopoulos problem there was just a
lot of foul careerism on the part of
some people around Clinton what's the
step not Stephanopoulos problem well a
lot of people thought that George
Stephanopoulos was out for his own
interests he wanted to convince
reporters and journalists that he was in
the know that he was important that he
was smarter than everyone else
therefore he talked to them much too
much and some former Clinton officials
think there was a lot of that going on
and it just didn't serve Bill Clinton's
interests very well and this played into
one of the more bizarre episodes of the
Clinton administration is it's really
incredible to think this kind of thing
thing happened in the White House but
when Clinton after the crushing
congressional defeat in 1994 he called
in Dick Morris
you know his most trusted
advisor from Arkansas to help him out to
basically come become his chief of staff
but he didn't tell any of the other
officials he would in some episodes hide
Dick Morris in his White House residence
and Clinton would go out with the speech
talk to George Stephanopoulos about it
Stephanopoulos would recommend some
changes and then Clinton would say well
I'll be right back I'm just gonna head
into the residence for a minute or two
I'll be right back anything comes out
with an entirely different speech
because Dick Morris is hiding in there
in order to change whatever changes
George Stephanopoulos has made and
really one of the reasons for this is
that Clinton didn't trust the people
around him enough to give them the
crushing news that they were being
supplanted by Dick Morris he feared what
they would tell the press and also some
other Clinton officials told me a reason
for this as a Clinton was just
conditioned to think that he was
vulnerable and that if the alienated
people who were close to him and had
been around him for a couple years they
were going to know secrets that would be
very dangerous for them to go and spread
around if they became alienated Dick
Morris said this I believe that Bill
Clinton totally and completely wasted
his second term partially due to his
laziness in 1997 and in 1998 he was
totally tanked up by the Monica and in
1999 and 2000 his entire presidency was
devoted to the single goal of getting
his wife elected to the Senate 2000 his
entire presidency was devoted here
that's that that's an exaggeration and
Dick Morris speaks and broad-brush terms
but I think is essentially right about
the second term and I would blame well
the ultimate blame goes to Clinton but I
partly blamed Morris for that as well
because he came up with a formula that
helped Clinton win re-election which is
let's let's poll everything you know
anything the score is 60% or so that's
very popular let's talk about that and a
lot of these things ended up being
minutia that is just contemptible in its
lack of importance v-chips and school
uniforms and teenage curfews and Clinton
won on those things in 1996 and some of
his more liberal idealistic aides like
Robert
rike told them what are you doing if you
get elected on these things you have a
mandate for nothing you're gonna have a
nothing second term and that's more or
less what ended up happening and it's
very stark if you just if you look back
at the sort of ambitions and statements
Hillary and Bill had initially you know
they conceived themselves as being the
new Franklin Delano Roosevelt and
Eleanor and this is what they ended up
doing though poling and sticking with
the easiest possible issues well the
first word first sentence of your book
first chapter by his second term Bill
Clinton's presidency had achieved a kind
of Seinfeld Ian self referentiality it
was a pret he was a president devoted to
his presidential legacy whatever that
might be how did you get your title like
I got it from him it was a word he
invoked all the time it's a word White
House aides were obsessed with according
to David Gergen at one point there had
to be a ruling from from the White House
from on high please do not use the word
legacy with reporters anymore and the
central irony and one of the central
themes of my book is Bill Clinton was
obsessed with his legacy he with every
fiber of his being wanted to be great
and then partly because of that self
obsession he never achieved it
you know George Bush whatever you think
of him has a grand and great goal in the
Middle East which is to fundamentally
shift its politics through the invasion
and occupation in the remaking of Iraq
that is a big ambition one of the
reasons he is able to pursue that as
he's not obsessed with himself and with
his legacy he's not sitting there
thinking well what do I do to be great
he's doing it because he thinks it's
important Bill Clinton was never able to
lift himself out of his own ego to imply
to apply his presidency to such a great
goal and and more importantly to take
such a great risk because he was always
too fearful of it I don't want to go
through the litany but you know people
who like Bill Clinton don't like George
Bush would say at this point well we had
eight years of prosperity more people
working than ever now we have
three million jobs that are gone and the
economy's been soft and we're in the
middle of a war costing us billions and
billions of dollars so which one do you
want right well that's exactly what they
say and they say it every day and what I
do in legacy is I take a chapter and
look at the economy and what made it
grow because what you've said is
extremely superficial soundbite I don't
blame you for saying it because it's
what they say but let's get into the
weeds a little bit and figure out what
policies are responsible for making the
economy grow that's what they never want
to do you know Sid Blumenthal
has written an 800-page book defending
Clinton in every single aspects
defending every jot and tiddle of every
lie but he just asserts in a couple
sentences that Clinton was responsible
for the economy Hillary Clinton who's
whose book is similarly ambitious in
terms of defending and puffing up the
Clinton record same thing just a couple
sentences asserting I go into it you
look at the recession in the early 1990s
it ended officially in March 1991 I was
about seven months before Clinton even
announced his candidacy in 1992 when
Bill Clinton's going up and down the
country saying this is the worst
recession we have experienced since the
Great Depression the economy was growing
at 3% annually it was a lie and it
wasn't even that recession in the early
1990s wasn't as bad as a recession in
the early 1980s which was much more
severe for good reasons so he gets in
he's run a campaign based on turning
around the American economy on huge
amounts of new federal spending alan
greenspan and other some of this
conservative economic advisors say
that's insane that will do nothing for
the economy he fortunately abandons all
those plans and totally reverses his
rhetoric on them and then he passes a
deficit-reduction plan in 1993 I go into
this a great length it didn't reduce the
deficit significantly it didn't make the
economy grow the economy was already
growing and it didn't reduce interest
rates that's the big justification for
it supposedly it reduced interest rates
and that set off an economic boom that
is false as well so what happened is in
the mid in late 1990s you had this huge
technology driven
boom in America we've had this kind of
periods of great economic creativity
before Bill Clinton his contribution of
it to it was to get out of the way
with various policies a hands-off policy
towards the Internet generally free
trade policy he signed a big tax cut in
1997 all these were good things if Bill
Clinton all his defenders would just say
I was the guy who got out of the way of
the great boom in the 1990s I would say
fine I would agree with that that was a
good thing that's not what they say that
instead they puff up this 1993 economic
plan in a way that is demonstrably false
to try to make it sound as though this
one small tax increase created the 1990s
boom the last sentence of your book I'm
not gonna read it for a second when I
ask you a question did you think it out
what do you mean by think it out did you
do it on purpose yes yes at what point
did you write the last sentence had you
had it written long before you got there
I had thought about do you want me to
talk about it before you yeah read the
lesson I had thought about that incident
and I the book ends with Bush's
inauguration Bill Clinton has been you
know up all night the last couple nights
are squeezing every last drop out of his
presidency and his power and pardoning
international fugitives and all the rest
of it and he's so exhausted that he
nodded off on the podium which is just
an extraordinarily undignified thing to
do I mean it's just amazing so I had
thought of that pretty far in advance as
the sort of perfect capstone for the
Clinton president well the sentence is
he fell asleep he fell asleep in the
earlier reference to this Seinfeld ian's
world what did you mean by that for
those who aren't Seinfeld followers
well Seinfeld's a show about the show
it's the Seinfeld show about Seinfeld
and Bill Clinton's legacy was going to
be ended up being about him seeking a
legacy but again not freeing himself
from his own self obsession and
weaknesses in ego enough to go out there
and take the kind of risks that it's
it's necessary
to have true presidential greatness back
to some more quotes mickey kantor who
was his trade representative that's
right i and the subject is monica
lewinsky it's his own fault this is a
quote to you exclusive no one did this
to him he did it to himself no one
brought this on him except himself was
that said in a hostile way over the
phone no I was in in person with Lejeune
Bernanke Kantor is very very nice man
very pleasant and it's look that's just
a common-sense thing to say and it
strikes us as perhaps a little
extraordinary that a Clinton official
would say that because so many of them
have been caught up in this ridiculous
defense of Clinton on the Monica matter
which is that you know it's all the
fault of you know three conservative
lawyers who conspired to get him no I
mean even Sid Blumenthal says this in
his book Clinton knew he knew full well
that the JFK rules that made it possible
for a president to fool around in the
White House and get away with it and
have the press ignored those rules were
gone he knew full well the consequences
of what he was doing and he did it
anyway and in that sense Cantor is
exactly right only he is to blame for
what happened Dick Morris again he was
terrified by blood because of his own
lack of a service record what's that
deluding too well Morris's theory is
that Clinton was afraid if he ordered US
troops into any action where they were
killed he would get viciously criticized
as luckier this draft dodger who was
sending our boys onto into these sort of
missions that you were weren't willing
to undertake yourself and that accounted
for his his caution I don't know whether
that that's sort of a psychological
theory I'm not whether I'm not sure
whether that's right or not but
certainly operationally something like
that was going on because all of
Clinton's wars were engaged mostly from
15,000 feet with the premise that there
should never be any American casualties
by the way did you try to talk to
Madeleine Albright or Bill Perry or I
know I know I tried to talk to Albright
I'm not sure I'm pretty sure I tried to
talk to Perry as well it all kind of
runs together james Woolsey former CIA
director
on Iraq quote so after a while they
fired a couple dozen cruise missiles
into an empty building in the middle of
the night which is a sufficiently weak
response to be almost laughable he's now
one of the big Hawks on the whole Viktor
akhi situation that's right well what
he's talking about is there was an
assassination attempt by the Iraqis in
Kuwait against former President Bush the
evidence of this was stark clear
unmistakable so Clinton had to do
something and I said all this wars were
fought mostly from 15,000 feet his other
great tool in war was cruise missiles
which also very risk-free
so they targeted the Iraqi intelligence
service building they made sure it was
empty in the middle of the night so no
one would be hurt and then they launched
these cruise missiles at it this is just
a stunningly flaccid response to a
foreign government targeting a former US
president but have very much
characterized the Clinton approach which
on all these military matters and on the
war on terror was just laughably weak
there's another wolves that quote I want
to ask you about I had no real
institutional problems or complaints
that a I didn't have the resources I
thought I needed this is at the CIA be I
virtually never got to see the president
except in large meetings had he ever
admitted that before I think he has I
think he has he I think he says don't
hold me to this but he met with Clinton
privately maybe twice and this is just a
stark demonstration of how little
Clinton really cared about national
security now you can say oh this is just
Jim Woolsey this is this guy who's gonna
become this this huge hawk and he just
didn't quite fit in well then there's
Louis Freeh who for a four year period
did not speak to Bill Clinton these are
the two guys you need most in fighting a
war on terrorism you're CIA director now
Woolsey was just there the first two
years and your FBI director and Clinton
actually explicitly made the FBI the
lead agency in fighting the war on
terror but he did not speak to his FBI
director and if you think about it
Monica
Winsky and kathleen willey had more
access to the president united states in
the 1990s than the director of the FBI
that's stunning you said that lilly free
did not have a White House pass that's
correct
now that was that well-known at the time
I'm not sure how well known that is
freeze attitude very upright upstanding
guy as I'm not going to get politicized
I'm not going to go there and hobnob
with with Bill Clinton because I'm
probably gonna have to end up
investigating him and he did have to end
up investigating him over and over again
and that was the seed of Clinton's
hatred and I use that word advisedly of
Louis Freeh is that free wanted to
investigate the China fundraising
scandal and Clinton was offended by that
so he cut Louis Freeh you know out of
his out of his orbit you talked to Lanny
Davis I did and I've got a quote on page
176 I was actually one of the point men
on the Lieberman side but I had a belief
that turned out to be right that if Joe
Lieberman made a moral statement on the
floor of the Senate but did not call for
Clinton's resignation he would save the
Clinton presidency he would serve as an
outlet for the pivot that I thought the
American people were prepared for he
would condemn the conduct pivot but it's
not worth driving him out of office
that's a quote from Lieberman so all I
did was call Joe and ask him what his
intentions were he told me and I thought
it was exactly the right pivot and I
told the White House I wouldn't touch
Lieberman is that new that that is mmm
that is new and you know Davis says
Clinton was a within inches of women
losing his presidency because if
Lieberman had said all the the
condemnatory things he said about
Clinton and therefore he should resign
that would have had an electric effect
and probably brought a lot of Democrats
along with Lieberman and really left
Clinton high and dry now what Lieberman
ended up doing was using his
condemnation of Clinton as a sort of
safety valve and that's what Davis is
referring to as the pivot and this
became the Democratic strategy we all
agree that this is a terrible awful
irresponsible thing the president has
done
but there should be no consequence for
it and that's the argument that
effectively carried the day we talked
you talked to Henry Hyde what did you
talk to him about I talked to him about
impeachment and then some other matters
having to do with his jurisdiction in
the Judiciary Committee with law
enforcement and whatnot but the are you
gonna read from a hide quote or you want
me to sure he this is the reason I'm
asking you all this is because again you
go back to the new information you have
in your book I was looking for a way to
resolve this we couldn't walk away from
pursuing the president but it was clear
that we would not get the two-thirds
vote in the Senate I had hoped to get
the majority anyway I had a couple of
our distinguished courteous centers
remain distinguished and courteous we
would have I thought having seen the
text of Feinstein's resolution of
condemnation which was stronger than our
bill of impeachment it was excoriating I
would not have been unhappy if it had
been adopted by the Senate had he said
that before no he had he hadn't this is
hyde saying in the senate he would have
been willing to go along knowing that
the cause was more or less lost with a
censure resolution which is something we
hadn't heard before and I think yeah I
defend the impeachment of Clinton I
argue he should have been impeached and
convicted and removed from office but I
think the end result was fairly
reasonable which is the impeachment
ended up serving as a kind of monster
censure and was an unmistakable
statement of disapproval of this man's
conduct the other thing you did was
quote extensively from other books
Jeffrey Toobin James Stewart Michael
Isikoff George Stephanopoulos Sidney
Blumenthal Peter Baker David Gergen
Bob Woodward Michael pattern et Benjamin
and Simon John Miller David Halberstam
Joe Klein Gail Sheehy I just mentioned
that too I want to ask you how do you
chose these books and have many other
people written books where they have
picked all these quotes out of these
books because you you mind them for yeah
as you were looking for well I just I
wanted to do a comprehensive account of
Clinton
presidency so I read everything and you
you read one book and you see references
to another book you go on to read that
book and the chain continues sometimes
seemingly forever when you're in the
midst of it and all why'd you trust that
other book though for have an accurate
quote well the you have to go on how
reputable the author is and I think all
those names you mentioned are considered
generally good and reputable journalists
and also I wanted to use a lot of the
Clinton people's own books you know Sid
Blumenthal's account or George
Stephanopoulos account of what the
president said is very trustworthy and
it's very hard for them to come back and
argue with me oh my gosh you know we
can't trust your source so that weren't
those two books written from different
really significantly different
perspectives or they they were
Stephanopoulos writing as the kind of
disillusioned former Clinton official
who had invested so many hopes and
Clinton's promise and then these these
hopes had been dashed and Blumenthal is
a defense of all things Clinton and
especially on the impeachment but I
don't think I haven't seen people
arguing that Stephanopoulos is
inaccurate or he's making up Clinton
quotes of all those books any one of
them stick out as being the best well
they all do different things and they're
all useful in their own way
Stephanopoulos is a great inside view of
the early administration but there might
be sort of too much Stephanopoulos in it
or too much detail for a lot of people
David marinus wrote a great biography of
Clinton but again you have to be really
really interested in Clinton to go back
and read you know all these details
about his years and at Oxford I think
all the impeachment books are good in
their own way whether it's to bin who
has a very different take than Mike
Isikoff this book is also very good or
Peter Baker who covers the actual fight
in Congress they all or sue Schmidt's
book which has a very good take from
Starr's perspective they all give you a
slightly different angle
footnote another subject footnote 88
under let me see
make sure I got the right chapter here
it's his presidency shrinking the office
chapter two Republicans were overmatched
in the negotiations says one staffer
quote misses a staffer speaking we would
walk in there totally unprepared dole
couldn't get a word out of his mouth
army didn't know the issues
Kasich John Kasich was running around it
was up to Newt and one thing he didn't
know how to do was play poker Clinton it
knew all he had to do was sit tight
interview with former GOP leadership
aide sounds to me like the leadership
baby was damning everybody that ran the
party well yeah it was the shutdown was
a great victory for Bill Clinton and
this aide is talking about negotiations
pretty late in the game where it's clear
that things of Clinton have shifted
Clinton's away and all Clinton has to do
is sort of string these string the
Republicans around convince him he
they're convinced them that he's
negotiating in good faith in order to
keep them around the table and just drag
things on knowing the longer they go on
the more Republicans are being hurt what
do you think of the Republicans all
through the eight years that's a good
question you know I I have some quotes
that are very hard on Newt Gingrich
actually for some other Republicans Newt
was a genius at understanding what had
to be done to take Congress but he was
not gifted at actually holding the
office of speaker and was his own worst
enemies in a lot of ways so one of
Clinton's foremost political
accomplishments was destroying Newt but
he had an awful lot of help in that and
in 1996 the Republican candidate Bob
Dole was just pathetic I mean he had no
ideas or issues and all he could say was
you know make attacks on Clinton's
character and I think obviously lots of
character flaws of Bill Clinton but
that's not going to just talking about
those things it's not going to win you
the presidency so Clinton in some ways
was gifted with a weak opposition in
some respects if you were to take his
same skills you used I'm looking back at
Bill Clinton's eight years and applied
them to the George Bush years what do
you think he'd come up
what would be the headline on your
legacy for George Bush a picture the
current George W Aaron George Dobie it's
really it's too early to say it depends
a lot on Iraq I mean he clearly has
leadership strengths he does have
principles I would argue he does have
the right character but it depends on
how Iraq turns out and if there is a
decent coherent government in Iraq that
occupies the central strategically
located area in the Middle East and
begins to reorient Arab politics and
change it that is huge accomplishment it
will change the Middle East and
literally the world but it's a risk and
now we're right in the middle of the
toughest part of it so it's it's early
to set too early to say do you think he
told the American people the truth
getting into the war I think he told
them the truth as he knew it I think in
some respects the intelligence was
obviously flawed but Bill Clinton relied
on exactly the same intelligence every
country in the world that had an
intelligence service was saying
basically the same things that Saddam
had had these weapons so this is
international politics you have to
operate on the information you have when
you have it and given what we knew at
the time he absolutely made the right
decision
in your terrorism chapter this quote a
few times we almost launched an attack
and found out later that the
intelligence was wrong says a former
Clinton official I was involved in a
situation when we almost launched a
cruise missile strike against the a
hunting party we almost blew up the
royal family of the United Arab Emirates
because they were out there pheasant
hunting when you come that close and
you're sitting at the principles meeting
and you have the adrenaline rush you say
using he use the f-word
we almost smoked these those guys it's
funny now but it wasn't funny then
high-ranking official yeah he was in on
these decisions on whether whether to
launch those missiles or not and that
this is that been told before the near
near launch on that hunt
party has been reported before but this
is a problem with the Clinton approach
they are trying to put a cruise missile
directly on a sama bin laden's head that
is really hard to do that takes really
good intelligence you know we've had
10,000 or more guys in Afghanistan for
two years or so and we still can't find
him what they should have done is what
Bush has done which is widen it out
we're not hunting one guy we are taking
away his assets and his network of
support most importantly and first and
foremost in Afghanistan and this is one
of the more damning things about Bill
Clinton's presidency he knew those
terrorist training camps were there in
Afghanistan we had pretty good
intelligence where most of these camps
were we knew they're producing
terrorists explicitly with the goal of
killing Americans and Bill Clinton did
not do anything serious about it he did
not even designate Afghanistan as a
state sponsor of terrorism which is
stunning why did you decide to do a book
on Bill Clinton in the middle of the
George Bush presidency well initially I
wanted to write a terrorism book I was
there in New York on September 11th my
department's about two miles from the
World Trade Center we smelled the
burning towers you know for weeks
afterwards in our offices at National
Review and as I looked into the mistakes
in American policy that had made us so
so vulnerable in such a terrible way
most of them were embodied by the
Clinton administration so I wanted to
write a book about the Clinton
administration's failures in the war on
terrorism but once you get into the
argument you realize that former Clinton
officials might say okay maybe we should
have done more on terrorism but gosh we
were unnecessarily distracted by the
Monica business and by impeachment or
maybe you know we should have paid more
attention to foreign policy but look at
the economy we created so the legacy is
all of a piece and I had to go in and
look at every aspect of it to get to the
bottom of it and that's what I did
what did you do before you became editor
of the National Review I I've been at
national view for about
years I started as a low-level editor
then I was a writer here in Washington
prior to becoming editor before that I
worked right out of college for Charles
Krauthammer the syndicated columnist as
a research assistant and then after that
for about a year and a half for a local
newspaper here in Virginia what's the
name of the newspaper there called the
connection newspapers their suburban
weeklies grew up in what town arlington
virginia went to school college were
University of Virginia when did you
first get interested in being a writer
it was in high school and it was through
perfectly enough Liam F Buckley
you know I saw his show firing line and
you know I enjoyed the argument I picked
up the magazine and I read his books and
from the time I was in high school I
realized I wanted to be an opinion
writer and I've been blessed to be able
to do it what was your family like why
were you interested at that time my
family my dad who's retired now was an
English professors there are a lot of
books around the house and I was always
a reader where was he a professor at
Trinity College a Catholic school in
Washington DC not a very political
household but an emphasis on reading
about your mom she was a social worker
in the city of Alexandria not very
political but a very bright woman and a
reader as well so what would you credit
your views to what it was it is it
William F Buckley your actual play
Buckley and and Reagan my parents were
Reagan voters you know they're turned
off the Democrats in the Carter years as
many middle-class families were you know
with an inflation and other economic
problems and you know the humiliations
abroad so I there's generally a
Republican environment in my household
but not extremely political or
ideological one in your acknowledgments
you have a couple of little things I
want to ask you about David Rifkin my
nominee for the next Secretary of State
read several chapters why is he your
nominee for that he'll he'll love that
you asked that question that that's
a little good-natured exaggeration but
he is a lawyer here in Washington and an
expert on international law and has been
very helpful to me in terms of
understanding international law and the
rules of warfare and also very generous
and reading portions of the book and
when you're you're an a would-be author
and you're the midst of writing a book
you are just so pathetically grateful
for people who take the time out to read
parts of the manuscript because
everyone's busy they have more important
things to do a manuscript is very rough
you know by Nature and there are a
couple people in particular who are very
generous with their time when did you
start this book in June June 2002 and
how many of these quotes that I've read
were in-person interviews versus over
the phone interviews most of them were
in person you just when you're in a room
with someone you establish a connection
it's not as disembodied and there tends
to be more trust did you tape the
interviews yes I taped them all I'd have
stacks and stacks of tapes what are you
gonna do with your tapes I I haven't
thought about that they'll probably end
up in a shoebox somewhere there's other
little things these questions are gonna
get tougher in in your knowledge myths
this one is Jennifer woulda checks
patient lot of check thank you patients
I'm sure he was correct that patience
and impatience with both were both
helpful in their own ways she is bright
beautiful and kind who is she she's my
girlfriend and this was a huge burden
for her because I wrote this book when I
was you know editor of National Review
when I was writing a syndicated column I
was appearing on TV with the Fox News
Channel so I had a lot going on so a lot
of the time to do this and the energy
came out of my personal life which
effectively meant it came out of my time
with her and when I say her patience and
impatience she was very supportive but
she was also very eager for me to finish
this thing and that helped goad me on
and finally a special thanks to Big
Daddy and to Borden who are the
Big Daddy is a colleague at National
Review named Kevin Longstreet and he's a
dear friend he's a great Yankees fan as
I am as well he likes a good time and
his nickname is Big Daddy Borden is
actually a friend of mine named Rick
Rick Anderson who is mentioned by name
elsewhere and the acknowledgments he's
the only one who got to think twice but
he's he does some acting down here in DC
and one of his first roles was a guy
named Borden so we joke a lot a lot
about Borden so I just put that in
knowing that he would enjoy it you
dedicate the book to mom and dad who
surrounded me with books and love and
then to Robert who laughs more than
anyone I know who's Robert Roberts my
older brother he's 40 years old he's
handicapped
so you never have a chance to do
something like this but he's most joyous
sort of jolly person I know which is
just a wonderful quality for anyone to
have and I wanted to acknowledge it in
the book you picked Regnery to publish
this book is this your first book it's
my first book Regnery right away
everyone knows it's conservative why did
you pick that imprint because they're so
good at conservative books they've been
doing it for a long time they know how
to sell them they know how to do them
and they're just wonderful to work with
and extremely patient and I should
mention one of the editors there Harry
Crocker who worked with me through most
of this you know when I was in my
struggles writing it you're you're
always you know you're descending into a
kind of neurosis when you're an author
trying to finish a book whenever I would
send him something you know a bit of a
Mannion a bit of the manuscript or a
question he would just say just keep on
keeping on you know that's not much
advice just keep going but it's exactly
right and that's all you can do as a
writer is just keep on going and
eventually after day after day after day
it it is going to add up to a book Harry
Crocker was our guest for his book on
robert e lee back to your book nixon
you're writing this Nixon's corruption
brought to power a cadre of aggressive
liberals you got you actually have to
listen very carefully to this to get it
Nixon's corruption brought to power a
cadre of aggressive liberals
clintons corruption expose liberals
thirst to defend what power they still
had Nixon's corruption attracted critics
whose idealism was forged in their fight
against his misconduct Clinton's
corruption attracted defenders whose
idealism was blunted in their fight to
defend his misconduct Nixon's corruption
led to the creation of a new edifice of
ethics legislation in Washington
clinton's corruption led to its
dismantling or irrelevance see how long
did it take you to write that paragraph
again that was a process of just
thinking about all the scandal politics
and that's the at the end of one of the
scandal chapters and in the Liberals
they created the Independent Counsel
statute and they loved it because they
knew the the Independent Counsel is
great at dogging and maybe even
destroying presidencies they created the
campaign finance rules they created the
sexual harassment rules and then they
get this guy in office who thumbs his
nose at all of it and then suddenly they
want to ignore it all and that's what I
mean by saying that their idealism was
blunted but parsed this paragraph for a
moment Nixon's corruption brought to
power a cadre of aggressive liberals
deal that well you had the Watergate
babies in Congress you had Woodward and
Bernstein and sort of investigative
reporters who tend to be liberals and
you have folks like Hillary Clinton who
were you know young lawyers on the
committees investigating Nixon who got
credentialed through that next sentence
Clinton's corruption exposed liberals
thirst to defend what power they still
had you I think a more idealistic bunch
would have kicked Clinton overboard and
said well you know we'll settle for Al
Gore you know that's that's good enough
but they're desperate to hold on to the
presidency and hold on to it and the
person of Bill Clinton because they just
thought he was so good politically
Nixon's corruption attracted critics
whose idealism was forged in their fight
against his misconduct basically the
same people I was talking about earlier
the Watergate babies the
journalist the Hillary Clinton crusading
lawyers Clinton's corruption attracted
defenders whose idealism was blunted in
their fight to defend his misconduct you
look at someone like Sidney Blumenthal
who's really just kicked over all
standards and idealism to defend this
guy this this extremely flawed person
and I can see saying arguing that some
of these Clinton policies were a success
despite the person of Bill Clinton and
what he did but that's not what someone
like Blumenthal argues he argues that
the you know policies were a miraculous
success and he was wonderful which is
just it doesn't pass the laugh test in
my mind what did you think of or what do
you think of the legacy of Richard Nixon
I think it was a poor one he you know
helped really send trust in the US
government into the tank with Watergate
which was a very real scandal
foreign policy and they taunt I don't
think were the right policy and were
eventually reversed to great effect by
Ronald Reagan and he expanded the
welfare state so from my perspective
there's not much to be said for him a
quote from Bernie Nussbaum whose job in
the Clinton administration was what
White House Counsel Lawrence Walsh was
probably responsible for Clinton's
election when he totally sandbagged the
Bush administration that's a quote to
you
that's a quote to me and that's he's
referring to the last-minute indictments
of CAP Weinberg and Weinberger and some
others that stalled any momentum that
the first Bush had in a 1992 election
and this I just want to say how much I
admire Bernie Nussbaum and Lanny Davis
because they are honest Clinton
defenders on the scandal stuff they're
honest about where the scandal machinery
started and who used it first which was
the Liberals and the Democrats and
someone like Bernie Nussbaum I haven't
heard him talk about the latest scandal
obsessing him in Washington the Wilson
affair but I am sure he's saying exactly
the same thing he said in the Clinton
administration which is we don't need a
special prosecutor special
prosecutors are always a mistake have
congressional investigations or have the
career Justice Department people do it
that is a consistent position times
almost said but Bill Clinton has the
gooiest foreign policy in history
absolute what does that mean it was
foreign policy as Social Work and you
know they thought it mattered a lot who
was cutting down trees in Ecuador and
you know what child well welfare policy
was in various places across the world
and what they could not do was identify
the enemies of the United States like
Saddam Hussein and Osama bin Laden and
go after them aggressively because
that's fundamentally what they didn't
like to do temperamentally they
preferred the Social Work and the goo if
somebody said we want another book out
of you and you were interested what
would you write it about right now based
on I have I have no idea no idea it was
so arduous that I want to take a
breather and last thing I want to do at
the moment is think about writing
another one the cover of the book looks
like this the name of the book is called
legacy paying the price for the Clinton
years by rich Lowry who is the editor of
the National Review and we thank you
very much thanks so much